شباب معنا من رفح مراسل الجزيره هشام زقوت
اهلا بك هشام اخر التطورات التي حملتها
الساعات الماضيه في قطاع
غزه اخر التطورات هو استمرار للقصف
الاسرائيلي خاصه في المناطق الشرقيه لخان
يونس هذه المناطق كانت تتعرض منذ اسابيع
الى قصف اسرائيلي عنيف الجيش الاسرائيلي
اعاد التموضع والتمركز فيها وانسحب من
مناطق مختلفه كعبان والزن وبن سيلا
القراره ومعا وكل هذه المناطق انسحب منها
واعاد التموضع فيها او تراجعت الدبابات
الاسرائيليه لكن القصف الاسرائيلي خلال
الساعه الماضيه يتركز في تلك المناطق
الجيش الاسرائيلي اقدم على تنفيذ عده
عمليات في تلك المناطق من خلال نسف بعض
المنازل في منطقه بنسه هيلا خاصه والجيش
الاسرائيلي ومنذ عده ايام يتبع هذا
الاسلوب من خلال نسف المنازل وتلغيم ومن
ثم تفجيرها وبعد ان كان يقصفها يدمرها
بالطائرات الحربيه الاسرائيليه او حتى من
قبل المدفعيه الاسرائيليه بات يتخذ من هذا
الاسلوب نهجا خلال الايام الماضيه نفذ
سلسله من عمليات التفجير في مدينه غزه في
شمال القطاع ايضا في المناطق الشرقيه لخن
يونس وايضا كذلك في المناطق الجنوبيه
الشرقيه لخن يونس منطقه بطن السمين ومنطقه
جورت لوت وبالتالي القصف الاسرائيلي
وعمليات النسف مستمره في اكثر من مكان
كذلك القصف ربما الاكثر عنفا والاكثر حده
هو في المناطق الجنوبيه الشرقيه وفي
المحور الجديد الذي توغل فيه الجيش
الاسرائيلي منذ عده اسابيع وبات ينفذ
عمليات قصف عنيفه على مناطق وسط البلد في
خانيونس وهذه المناطق باتت هي المسرح
الاهم والاخطر ربما خلال الايام الماضيه
من خلال عمليات الاستهداف المباشر من خلال
العمليات القصف الاسرائيلي المباشر ايضا
في خان يونس في مناطق وسط البلد في
المناطق الجنوبيه الشرقيه محيط مستشفى
ناصر محيط مركز حي الامل ومستشفى حي الامل
في وسط البلد في حي الامل في خانيونس وكل
هذه المناطق تتعرض الى قصف عنيف من
المدفعيه ومن الطائرات الحربيه
الاسرائيليه الخطير في هذا الموضوع ان
محيط مستشفى ناصر هو يتعرض كذلك الى
استهداف وبالتالي هذا يزيد من الضغط على
الاطباء على الممرضين على الطاقم الطبي في
المستشفى ونحن لا نتحدث عن اي مستشفى نحن
نتحدث عن المستشفى الاكبر في قطاع غزه بعد
خروج مستشفى ومجمع الشفاء الطبي عن الخدمه
وهذا يعني ويهدد هذا المستشفى بشكل كبير
وهذا يعني ان خروج هذا المستشفى عن الخدمه
بكل تاكيد يهدد بكارثه صحيه وطبيه خطيره
لان هذا المستشفى هو المستشفى الاكبر هو
المستشفى الذي يحتوي على عدد الاسره
الاكبر على عدد غرف العمليات الاكبر بعد
خروج اغلب مستشفيات قطاع غزه عن الخدمه
بسبب نقص الوقود او نفاذ المستلزمات او
بسبب الاستهداف المباشر من قبل الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي في مدينه غزه في شمال القطاع
جميع هذه المستشفيات في الشمال وفي مدينه
غزه خرجت عن الخدمه بفعل الاستهداف
المباشر لها من قبل الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
بالتالي استمرار استهداف الاحتلال لمحيط
هذه المستشفيات مستشفى حي الامل مستشفى
الامل ومستشفى ناصر بكل تاكيد يهدد هذه
المستشفيات بالخروج من جديد عن الخدمه
وتهديد حياه الاف المواطنين الذين يتلقون
الخدمه والرعايه الصحيه في هذه المستشفيات
من جرحى من مرضى من مصابين من جراء هذه
العمليات المستمره والقصف الاسرائيلي
المستمر المحور المهم ايضا هو مدينه غزه
شمال القطاع بعد ان عادت الغارات الى
الايام الاولى وكان الى الايام الاولى من
الحرب وكان الايام الاولى تعيد نفسها من
خلال استهداف الجيش الاسرائيلي وتكثيفه
للغارات في مدينه غزه وايضا في شمال
القطاع في منطقه جباليا في جباليه البلد
في جباليه المخيم وكذلك في مناطق بيت
لاهيه وبيت حنون لكن القصف المركز كان على
مناطق جباليه وهذه المناطق كانت تتعرض منذ
بدايه الحرب الاسرائيليه وكذلك منذ منذ
بدايه التوغل البري في جباليا الى عمليات
قصف اسرائيلي مستمر الى قصف من الجو
واليوم تعود عمليات القصف الاسرائيلي الى
تلك المناطق ايضا مناطق مدينه غزه خاصه
المناطق الغربيه في مدينه غزه منطقه دوار
ابو مازن ومنطقه الرمال الجنوبي باتت
تتعرض الى قصف عنيف الغارات تستهدف منازل
مدنيه فلسطينيه شقق سكنيه كما شاهدنا
بالامس وخلال فجر هذا اليوم وصباح هذا
اليوم كانت هناك عمليات استهداف لعدد من
المنازل وكذلك القصف المدفعي لم يتوقف
ايضا من محيط مستشفى الش فقط ان انوي بهذا
الخبر العاجل على شاشتنا عن مراسل الجزيره
اشتباكات بين المقاومه الفلسطينيه وجيش
الاحتلال الشرق خان يونس جنوب قطاع
غزه ال الملفت الان ايضا ان كل استهداف
للمنازل هشام يسفر عن عدد كبير من الشهداء
لان هناك نازحين كثر يتجمعون في ما بقي من
منازل في غزه يعني هذا يرفع بشكل اكبر
حصيله الشهداء خصوصا في رفح حيث
انت بالفعل القصف الاسرائيلي في اي منطقه
خاصه في مدينه غزه او في رفح في جنوب
القطاع هو يوقع عشرات من الشهداء والجرحى
في مدينه غزه ربما عدد السكان قليل بسبب
عمليه النزوح لكن الناس هناك لا تجد لا لا
ماوي ولا مراكز للايواء ولا منازل قائمه
الجيش الاسرائيلي و منذ بدايه الحرب
الاسرائيليه يستهدف المنازل يستهدف
المباني والابراج السكنيه وبالتالي دمر
احياء بكاملها احياء مثل حي تلله كان
يحتوي على عشرات من الابراج السكنيه
جميعها دمرت في حي الكرامه في حي المقوسي
وفي حي الرمال اشهر احياء مدينه غزه دمر
ومسح عن وجه الارض وبالتالي المنازل
القائمه في مدينه غزه وفي شمال القطاع هي
منازل عددها قليل وبالتالي الناس تلجا الى
هذه المنازل رغم انها ليست منازلها في
كثير من الاحيان للاحتماء من البرد القارس
الاحتماء من عملي القصف الاسرائيلي واطلاق
النار وبالتالي تكون هناك هذه المنازل
مكتظه عن بكره ابيها اعداد كبيره من
السكان من اكثر من عائله القصف الاسرائيلي
على مدينه غزه بكل تاكيد يوقع عشرات من
الشهداء والجرحى اذا كانت شقه سكنيه توقع
عشرات من الشهداء والجرحى فما بالك بمبنى
سكني يحتوي على عدد من الشقق السكنيه ايضا
في مدينه رفح نحن نتحدث عن حرب من نوع
مختلف اذا كانت هناك عمليات ص فنحن نتحدث
عن العشرات والعشرات من الشهداء والمصابين
والمفقودين المنازل عن بكره ابيها ممتلئه
للغايه كان يسكن في رفح 300000 نسمه اليوم
يسكن مليون و300 ال نسمه ولك ان تتخيلي ان
الارصفه يتواجد عليها خيام فيها نازحون
المباني كلها ممتلئه فيها نازحون
وبالاضافه الى سكان هذه المدينه الذين
يستضيفون هؤلاء السكان وهؤلاء النازحين
وبالتالي اي عمليه قصف اسرائيلي هي توقع
عشرات من الشهداء والجرحى والمفقودين ايضا
الجيش الاسرائيلي هناك في هذه منذ بدايه
الحرب الاسرائيليه يحاصر قطاع غزه
وبالتالي توفير المؤن والمقومات الحياه
والمواد الاساسيه لهذا العدد الكبير من
السكان في رفح على وجه الخصوص بالتاكيد
يعني هناك عمليه صعبه كارثيه في ظل شح
المواد الاساسيه في ظل نقص المساعدات
والمساعدات عددها قليل وعدد الشاحنات قليل
للغايه اضافه الى توفير الادويه
والمستلزمات الطبيه لهذا العدد الكبير من
السكان بكل تاكيد هذه عمليه صعبه وخطيره
ايضا للغايه في ظل استمرار القصف
الاسرائلي شكرا لك هشام زقوت مراسل
الجزيره كنت معنا من رفح